c'est l'autre bataille du capitaine
Vadim récupérer 9 de ces hommes fait
prisonnier par les Russes dans le
don-basse
un combat qu'il mène avec leur mère
leurs épouses et leur sœur
les voici filmées par la télévision
russe après leur capture en juin dernier
près de la ville de sévero deniers
ils avaient beaucoup plus de soldats que
nous
notre commandant nous a ordonné de
reculer et ils ont commencé à attaquer
nos positions par l'arrière
le combat s'est engagé très dur pendant
deux heures
l'artillerie nous a ciblé et l'ennemi
beaucoup plus nombreux est entré par le
côté gauche de l'une de nos positions
les plus importantes c'est là que mes
hommes ont été capturés
depuis les familles nom de nouvelles que
par les vidéos de propagande russe ici
les soldats sont mis en scène devant des
livres supposés à prendre aux Ukrainiens
à se dénaziers
seul Aliona colsova a pu avoir un
contact direct avec son mari
pendant une minute à peine
il m'a dit que ça allait qu'il était
prisonnier et qu'il était détenu avec
les autres soldats qu'ils étaient
ensemble
il m'a dit d'embrasser les enfants une
semaine après il y a une vidéo postée
sur les sites russes où j'ai vu mon mari
et les autres ils étaient combien déjà 5
au moins ils étaient en vie mais je les
voyais en train de travailler en train
d'enterrer des soldats
cette vidéo la voici
Vadim sait que la vie de ces hommes est
faite de privations et de travail forcé
il veut obtenir un échange avec des
prisonniers russes
nous aussi on a des prisonniers et des
choses qui peuvent intéresser l'ennemi
ces 9 soldats ont défendu la région de
Louhansk pied à pied
maintenant village par village on libère
le don-basse
son unité vient de reprendre aux forces
russes la ville de Limone
des succès tactiques difficiles à
célébrer pour le capitaine tant que ces
hommes ne sont pas libres
la guerre en Ukraine qui